hi how are you i am well how about you
good thank you
i thought your character was just so
great in this i mean you're so terrific
in this your character seems like
somebody that i would want to hug but
would also be afraid she might slap me
while i did it
is the word that you found fun to play i
mean she is very
hot and cold is that fun to go back and
forth with especially not knowing when
it might come out
it can be it can be fun to play a
character that is that is really hot and
cold and there were moments where it was
fun
um
and some ended up on the cutting room
floor but
[Laughter]
but it was fun because i think that she
anytime you get to play an extreme
in that circumstance
is a great thing um so
you know there was there's a moment
where
she's just broken down and it's a really
extreme
moment and it becomes
pretty humorous um because here's this
woman who you think nothing can chip her
and she's just like she can't handle it
she can't get herself together um
but um
you know it's also
it's interesting because when you think
of people like that people that you see
i love that you wanted to give her a hug
because i think most people would not
have wanted to give her a hug unless
they just wanted to rub her sweater
[Laughter]
but she needed a hug she is someone who
really really needed a hug um so i'm
glad that you saw that
yeah i mean maybe not the first time we
meet her but she does
eventually like someone who could really
use a hug
did you know that there were going to be
so many ups and downs with her that it
would be such an emotional rollercoaster
i mean
because we do get to see more and more
of that as it goes on
no i didn't know it was going to be such
an emotional roller coaster i had
actually zero idea um and it was
shocking
to me
to read some of the things as they as
they came up and that it would become so
layered
i just didn't know that that was going
to happen and um
you know so
quite a lovely challenge as an actor to
have that
tossed in your lap oh by the way here's
episode
[Laughter]
we'll be doing a zoom reading tomorrow
um you know so there were a lot of
surprises that that came my way and um
and i'm glad for them because i feel
like
um
that's what happens as a person moving
through life things come your way that
you're not ready for things come your
way that are very intense and um i was
really glad that you didn't stay in one
zone
in one lane because that's boring um
it's really boring
this is not a boring woman at all
i actually really enjoyed the dynamic
between alex and regina because their
worlds are so different from each other
what did you most enjoy about exploring
that relationship and exploring it with
margaret quality because your scenes
together are just there's just so many
things happening
[Music]
thank you um well margaret and i really
got along very well we enjoyed each
other um quite a bit
and we both love music we both love arts
and
we just we laughed a lot really um
i think that
what i loved about that relationship is
that they start out looking very far
apart and as you move forward you
realize
that there's not so much distance
between them um
as far aside from checkbooks you know
what i mean that they do connect as
women um
that they do have
um a through line with each other and
that they are able to speak the same
language and everybody feels
you know everybody feels the same way
everybody
um you prick them they bleed and i think
that they had to realize that about each
other
in order to come together
i absolutely love the moment where alex
becomes determined to stand up for
herself and regina just happens to be
the person that happens with for that
scene in in the parking lot when she's
returning her dog what's that whole
thing
like to shoot
that scene particularly
that whole confrontation i mean
there it was just
there was just a lot happening there
there was a lot happening there and it
was freezing
outside
um and i think it might have been the
first or second scene that we shot
actually
um
[Music]
and
and uh
it was really interesting because also
margaret was still finding alex because
we were so early in the shoot
and we were both
sort of finding our footing and where we
were in that space
and then you had the other character
from the shelter who was off on the
corner who his name i can't remember
terribly
who's phenomenal in the show
um
it was
it was interesting and it was really
exploration and it was wild because
margaret is like six inches taller than
i am like so
i'm like trying to hold my ground and
i'm like this the whole time because
she's so tall
um
but it was fun it was fun and it was
silly and that dog weighs more than you
think
[Laughter]
but it was it was fun
no matter what else you do you will
always be a disney princess what does
that mean to you what what does tiana
and having had a creation you know a
hand in the creation of who she is mean
to you
you know it still means the world to me
i mean
tiana will be here
um
forever and
it's a beautiful gift
and it's something that continues to
touch children which
makes me
deeply happy and deeply proud
at the same time um but it gives me joy
because i love to see their little faces
light up when they when they figure out
who th what the voice who this voice is
and sometimes they don't get it
sometimes they're like i'm hearing this
voice
but you don't look like a cartoon
but it's um
it's a gift it really truly is a gift
and i and i have i don't think i'll ever
not be
deeply appreciative to be able to
inhabit that spot um and to be able to
leave that behind me when i'm gone
are you also excited about the fact that
we'll soon get to have a disneyland
attraction
themed for princess and the frog i mean
are you like waiting to go on the ride
when it's all done
i cannot wait to go on the ride because
i love a ride
um
i you know
the crazier the better a loop-de-loop
backwards upside down i'm very happy
um i love tower of terror so i love that
it's going to be it's not going to be
some little soft meander through the
bayou you know what i mean with the
occasional mosquito noise it's going to
be a real ride and i think that that's
so apropos because tiana went on a ride
before becoming the princess you know
she had a journey um an adventure so i'm
really excited about it and what it's
going to turn out to be and i know the
imagineers are going to create something
fantastic because they're excited about
it
um so it's really thrilling
yeah i'm i'm a scaredy cat so i have
never been on the ride before and
because i love princess and the frog so
much i'm actually gonna have to drag
myself onto
the ride probably watching through my
hand because i'll be
terrified but i can't not go on it so
thank you so much thank you i hope you
enjoy it i think it's going to be loads
of fun yeah it's about time so i'm just
happy about that
indeed
what what do you think regina's life
looks like after alex leaves do you
think that she got a better handle on
the whole mom thing did you think about
like how how she might be doing with
that
i think she will have a better handle on
things because
i think that regina will be less
concerned with making things perfect
and i think that that's one thing that
infants teach people
it's not going to be perfect
if you're going to have throw up on your
shirt you know i am going to poop at the
least opportune moment um
[Music]
i'm going to be awake when you want to
be asleep there's no room for perfection
in there and i think that that'll make
regina
much looser much happier
and
i think it's going to fulfill her in a
very different way because it'll be
something that she cannot control and
won't want to
control
um
yeah
that's it i think
now the house might be a mess
yeah but
this is a big house um but i think that
it will matter less to her it's it's my
hope
well thank you for talking to me about
it you're really great in this and i
can't wait to drag myself on the ride so
thank you very much
thank you have a great one